[Musique]
non ce n'est pas ces questions au sein
des banques de petite ville c'est en
métal c'est pas terrible est en fait une
association dans le quartier qui
s'appelle la maison pour tous en gros
seins qu'on dise qu'elle me mouvoir en
discuter avec nous ils nous avaient dit
ben la ligue 1 on voit que vous verrez
sur le skatepark
est ce que ça vous intéresserait de
participer à un projet pour un nouveau
skatepark floués
du coup pas nous ont faits disent
carrément et du coup on commence à voir
avec la mairie et caetera et
et en gros il ya eu une première réunion
qui se sont mises en place ou en fait
beaucoup il ya le
avec une communauté en fait de
l'amérique est elle a donc le comité des
sports le maire et serra et puis on a
posé le sujet selon la pause et le
projet sur la table et ils ont dit il
invite à écouter on va c'est de voter ça
avec la commission ils vont voir avec la
région et cetera nous ça a été voté ce
budget a été voté un budget d'à peu près
six cent cinquante mille euros si la
mairie a fait à chercher un peu les
entreprises qui pouvaient faire de skate
park et c est ce qu un parc en fête
après il emploie des personnes pour les
pour la construction et un gros
constructeurs entreprises par seyed nous
donner un petit ordinaires ont fait des
spect art qu'ils ont fait marignac entre
constructeurs venus saluer des premières
idées donc on est un peu les
brainstormings au niveau des idées pour
ce qu'on voulait surtout pas et du coup
bas surtout les bmx ancêtres étaient là
avec la dernière demi-heure du coup à
l'époque pour nous mais des réunions du
coup ils ont commencé à faire les
premiers plans et en fait les fois que
ce premier plan a été validé à peu près
dès le début donc on avait en a vu au
québec bol y avait du coup toute la
suite façade arrière et c est en fait en
l'espace de
c'est un espace de deux ans le projet
était commencé à planter le skate park a
commencé quelque chose construit et
c'est parti de là et en fait là donc du
coup l'été après la construction coûtera
donc en fait une inauguration qui a eu
toute la team en clis qui étaient mon
gros sting d'ascq est française
vous pouvez partir de là on a commencé à
émettre des prêts une association c'est
un coup dur au saint père ni rentrer au
but mais de pouvoir découvrir un
événement là au niveau du 31 août l'a
dernièrement
et puis on espère faire des nouveaux
projets a parfois à partir de là et
pouvoir faire développer un peu
skatepark développer le site et faire
que les teintes bus et pouvoir créer des
trucs que tu trouves la schola parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a quand même la grosse
infrastructure mais maintenant il faut
en fait de tous par les vidéos si on les
met sur un stade entier des montages
vont bien enroulé donc ils sont gros de
la région le ski le parc le plus gros de
la région ne sait pas quand on a un bolt
est énorme
parce que vous par exemple à châteauroux
albert nbc à peu près il ya un beau look
lé championnat de france qui
s'organisait la bafin une étape des
championnats france là-bas il ya le fils
qui s'est fait y'a pas longtemps et
après ça on a un bolt est encore plus
gros que et
mieux roulé de choses à faire devant il
ya plus de ligne par an le départ qui
est énorme au niveau de la streak pads a
donc toute la partie escaliers bancs etc
on a tous bagis reprendre les phrases il
a dit contrairement aux autres cas de
parcs en france ce que lui il avait
roulé par exemple l'avantagé ici bas il
ya tout et l'avantagé cas du petit et du
gros et pour apprendre cette oeuvre pour
que vous progressez apprendre des
nouveaux tracés génial qu'en fait il ya
vraiment de quoi prendre ses décisions
ce soit pour les enfants même les plus
âgés à peu près tout le monde je pense
que tout le monde s'y retrouve ici ça
c'est cool